the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
so welcome to the second lab which as we
promised will primarily focus on audio
recording both this sort of specific
technical aspects of setting up our
audio package what's in it what it can
do and also some general tips on getting
good recordings again this is not a
class in digital signal processing or
very intense field recording we're
really going to focus on the basics of
what you can do to improve the audio
that you record and this really
fundamental things that you needed to be
thinking about so some of you again as
with with the camera I mean if some of
you have audio recording experience or
or are very interested in audio this may
seem like old hat or very simple to you
but we're going to be starting at a
basic level with it assumes no prior
knowledge before we do that though I
want to as we discussed go back and take
a look at some of the stuff that was
shot last week it's very interesting
choices were made and we're going to go
through it and talk about what worked
what could be improved some of the
technical challenges that that that were
faced and then based on that we can do a
little bit of a review and an expansion
of various things you can do with the
camera both in terms of framing and film
grammar as we've been talking about as
well as technical things so I'm going to
dive right in
put together just a few clips all silent
i took the audio out because it was all
camera mic and
yep um well let's find out mm okay
starting right with a close-up so if you
recall what the exercise was it was to
film seven or eight different kinds of
things including portraits of people and
this is I I picked a random sampling
it's not everything that everyone shot
but it's a series of shots that were
interesting for one reason or that had
challenges for one reason or another so
this is the first thing and this is just
you know first of all in terms of
framing a really nice portrait it's a
really nice shot I mean you it's very
engaging it's very interesting the
framing is nice it's a little bit
off-center so there's some energy in the
frame the challenge of course is and I
should go back there are some technical
issues the primary one being exposure
and you can see that we're losing a ton
of detail in in the brighter parts of
the frame and you were probably a couple
of stops overexposed here now what what
you can do of course in in editing is
attempt to fix that bring it down adjust
and we can make it look better but this
is fairly fairly extreme on the
overexposure side and it would be
obviously a lot better to get it right
now what's interesting is that this is
also kind of an example of breaking the
rules mean this is a very kind of dreamy
sort of kind of soft feel to it and
fashion photography it often has that
kind of blown out the blown-out whites
that you're looking at here but I I
don't think this was intentional I'm not
sure maybe it was it sort of works but i
would i would say the concert and
getting a good exposure first and and if
you're not sure of your own kind of
skill at reading you know judging
exposure in manual what you can do is go
to auto exposure and zoom in on the
person's face
find out what auto exposure wants to do
go back to manual and then the face is
probably going to be relatively properly
exposed it depends on skin tone of
course that's you know most cameras are
designed for Caucasian skin tone and so
if you are filming people with darker
skin tones you may want to open up a bit
did you can also use the spot meter yes
yeah the second page of the personal
menu I think it's the bottom right or
something like that right but the spot
meter acts a lot like the spot focus
once you select it you use your finger
right on the LCD screen and you just
press what it is you want to properly
expose and it will expose that and in
something like this background would be
blown out but it's not really what you
care about anyway yes oh wait anyways in
most cases you want to expose for
people's faces properly which is why you
can either zoom in on the face get an
exposure in auto or use the spot meter
pull back out and get get a decent
exposure now if you're shooting a very
very wide shot of course that may not be
the case it may be fine to underexpose a
person's face in order to get the sort
of environment properly exposed and
again you know it's just the the way
these cameras are set up that they are
set up to expose as I said Caucasian
skin tones so for darker skin tones you
may want to open up a half a stop a stop
whatever and that's something that
you're going to have to learn to judge
but but as I said I mean this is kind of
very pleasing shot the framing is very
nice a little bit shaky a little bit in
uncertain
again you know kind of interesting just
a very interesting way of shooting a
person I mean there's a something I like
these two shots again there's an
exposure issue i think there's also a
bit of a white balance issue with both
of these but it's a little bit hard to
tell because the exposure is so high
that we're also losing a lot of detail
on the color so so again you know think
about those 4 f's white balance of
course not being one of the f's but but
the point is that you need to think
about kind of your technical aspects and
it just becomes kind of routine you know
set up the camera make sure it's in
focus make sure it's properly exposed
think about what your focal length is
and determine it in relation to this
kind of shot you want to shoot make sure
that the color balance the white balance
is correct and you just kind of run
through it and then you're ready to go
but again the both of these shots are
very nice portraits
so here's another one this is is an
interesting frame I like the the the
off-center nature of the frame the big
issue here is focused and as you can see
her face is out of focus the background
is sharper than the face and one of the
things that we're going to review at the
end of this is ways of getting proper
focus I think you know Dave and I kind
of ran through focus relatively quickly
and it's worth reviewing Andrey
emphasizing because focus again is one
of those kind of non-negotiable items
each there are lots of rules you can
break you can overexpose the the frame
if you I know what you're doing and you
have a really good reason you can frame
things unconventionally but focus it
should always be in focus even if you
blur it later you really you should need
to shoot in focus so so that's just kind
of a basic and and we will talk about
ways of making sure that what you want
is in focus and not what you don't want
I mean again here the issue is that the
background is is sharper than the
person's face and I think here I think
you may have been just sort of working
on that then quite didn't didn't quite
come off but anyway we'll talk about
focus and and again how you just can
kind of it just kind of becomes second
nature or have it to to check focus on
whatever it is that you want to have
emphasized we have shambling giant
cruising through and both of us are so
awkward on camera David like you'll see
me in a minute it's horrible look like
this is a bridge to jump off of it now
what's interesting is that you shot this
several times and and that was that was
great the first time you see again you
know we talked about where people should
be positioned in the frame the camera
really wasn't keeping up with the Dave
he was just really writing the right
side of the frame so you were clearly
working on that and this one is somewhat
better
it would still be a more effective shot
if he could always stay a little bit on
the left since he's walking to the right
because it's just better to show where
the person's heading and give it gives
them more energy like that they're
moving into the space on the right but
it also can be can be tricky as you know
Dave you're not moving very fast there
but if people are moving fast obviously
it can be tricky it's called pushing the
frame like one yeah it looks like
they're pushing the frame as they walk
rather than right it's sort of like you
know you it sort of like the
unresponsive camera person like oh I
didn't expect that the other thing just
to review his head room you can see that
there it would be again preferable given
the size of the shot and so on if if you
weren't chopping the top of his head
although you know it starts out frame
pretty well like you know eyes are up in
the top third here the zoom out is a
little shaky but it's a good idea this
one's a little better again also i like
i love the reveal of this guy what
anyway that was unintentional but but
that there's a good example of that or i
mean it's a good example of revealing
something i mean this is a classic you
know film trope that one piece of action
leads into something else that then it
reveals itself so if in fact dave was
just an extra in your film and that guy
was your main character and he was
freaking out because he was late for
something and he didn't know where he
was that we kind of an interesting way
to injure you know introduce that
unintentional but but again think about
how you reveal things using one kind of
action to reveal another or motion to
reveal something you don't always have
to have everything you know square kind
of like presented boom in the frame
so this is kind of an interesting angle
I mean we talked about their Tov you
know his sort of use of very low very
high very different kinds of angles this
is a not quite as intense version of
that but again it's not head on it
actually works really well because you
have these diagonals going up in the
staircase and it you know it really sort
of emphasizes what the action is this
person going down the ladder and then
down the stairs now one small thing I
think I mentioned this in the first
class about being decisive with the
camera you know act like you know what
you're doing even if you feel that you
don't and one of the things that's going
on there is you see those little zoom
zoom in the zoom out there very
tentative sort of like should I be
tighter no maybe wider no I'm not sure
and you know you know you just have to
act like you know what you want even if
you aren't sure so if you're thinking I
want to zoom in here you know you want
to start zooming in and then until you
find something that seems worth zooming
into and then pull back out zooms are as
we've talked about zooms are kind of
tricky it's their kind of too easy and
and its people a lot of people are just
completely against zooms when it comes
to documentary work and so on just
because it's clear it easy to sit in one
place and just get a bunch of different
shots but if you're going to use that if
you're going to move the camera in any
way zooming or panning or handheld you
really want to as I said kind of act
like you know what you're doing even if
you feel you really don't so if I'm
shooting this class I move over to Dave
Oh Dave's not doing anything interesting
well I still did that so I'm going to do
it I'm going to sell that shot and if
it's a terrible shot if he's you know
picking his nose or something I'll bail
out of it as quickly as I possibly can
and get back to something else so I
won't don't waste a lot of time what I
don't do is is that interesting um well
maybe no he's taking his own you know
because then I didn't get anything so so
again it's just
thing that it kind of becomes second
nature I did we talk about David
McDougal in the film trance I forget
said do you want to say something about
that oh well just there's a documentary
filmmaker David McDougal and I don't
remember if he's on the reading list
this year what's up I was on Roush Oh
film trance say oh ok I thought that was
no mcdougal but McDougald talks I guess
use a different term so anyway anyway he
talks about it too but so John Roush a
filmmaker that that will be looking at
later in the class talks about something
that he calls us in a trance which is
basically the the mode you get in when
you're shooting a scene and he's
documentary scene to scene that you're
not really controlling where you're so
immersed in it and and you're it you
know people are kind of interacting with
you you're interacting with them you're
making choices as the action unfolds
about being you know what you're
shooting how you choose to shoot it you
know the angle you're choosing to shoot
the next thing you're going to do the
and the choices that you make almost
instinctively when you're that immersed
in in a scene and another way to talk
about it is that whatever you're doing
is right it's very spontaneous you know
like again when I say act like you know
what you're doing even if you don't it's
kind of it's kind of similar because
it's you're responding you're responding
to whatever is happening around you and
so you can't make a wrong choice if you
do make a wrong choice you get out of it
really quickly but the choice you've
made instinctively if you trust yourself
you know trust yourself to follow follow
that up you know why did I want to pan
over to Dave maybe you know
there is something very hypnotic that it
just was part of the discussion
get so and I have done that achievement
but but when you do do it and you get
really into it it does become something
like not in this basically to talk about
say people who do work hard or more for
making that they had a sense of sort of
themselves be invincible because you get
so kind of caught up in fraying that you
just follow everything it's not like a
normal experience of the world and it
become can become really a ticket to
start to see through the camera to the
camera frame and there's a if you
remember from bar known as a discussion
of about Hoffman who was the one the
brother of your top we did a lot of the
shooting and we would go on and he went
on this vacation we needed to bring his
camera and he was so sort of disturbance
in the world without camera because he
become sort of addicted to seeing the
world of the camera that you know the
vacations watch over him so there is
just something really hypnotic about you
know once you're seeing the world
through this camera I
I had that experience I mean I've never
you know done anything like war
photography but I was shooting
aerobatics in a light plane at one point
and we were doing all these insane crazy
things that I would have been absolutely
terrified to have been involved in but I
was shooting it and I didn't care it was
I was just you know I was like whoa you
know this is amazing we're diving and
then we're flying along the highway a
foot off the ground and then we're
climbing vertically enrolling and it was
just great I loved it but if I had not
had the camera I would have been
completely terrified because that's not
you know my idea of fun so anyway so
let's moving on so this is we did the
following so this is quite a cool shot
you you know the way it's introduced
with the shadow and then hands up doors
locked of course so we tried that
several times just full disclosure I
think the first couple were not as
successful so that's another thing to
think about if you're interacting with
their subject and your subject is
cooperative and it doesn't work the
first few times you can you can keep
doing it you saw that again with Dave
and the pan so you know it took a few
times for for you to work out how would
the shadow reveal the person oh that
didn't work well trying to try something
else but but you know that was a was a
nice shot another you know of course
can't resist a mirror
so here we have some handheld following
this is um yeah a little shaky but quite
a nice shot and just to talk about
handheld for a moment one of the things
that I think will do I talked about how
we're going to go over focus I think we
should also talk about techniques for
handheld holding the camera how to sort
of smooth yourself so there's that
technical aspect of it but then there's
also the choice of how do you frame your
subjects and how do you choose whether
or not you're you're going handheld and
what works about this is that you're
following a person first of all it's
it's a handheld shot that could have
better be shot on the tripod is just a
shaky shot or potentially shaky shot
this works because the you're following
person is walking I mean it's obvious
but it's worth saying there's also it's
a wide shot and and wide focal lengths
work much better in handheld because
they're smoother and it's also kind of a
pleasing frame you have these you know
these horizontals converging kind of in
the center of the frame so here we have
another handheld another in our genre of
tripod carrying shots this is a
it's kind of a little washed out because
of the light
so again kind of shaky but I mean going
downstairs is very difficult I one of
the things that might help would be
paying more attention to the verticals
and horizontals you see we're very out
of it real tilted angle here what's kind
of interesting about this shot is that
the frame changes a lot and this is
another thing that you can do with a
moving camera that's kind of cool so it
starts out with kind of a wide shot of
me walking and then it turns into and
over-the-shoulder shot of me walking and
then the camera comes around and now i'm
in a closer shot and you're walking
backwards so one of the reasons to do a
handheld shot or a moving shot is so
because that you can make the frame more
fluid you can do a wide shot that turns
into a close-up that turns into an
over-the-shoulder shot that turns into a
medium shot and again what works about
this is is that and the fact that some
you know I'm being followed that there's
there's action in the frame that's
initiating the moving camera and my my
main suggestion would be first of all as
i said to really think about the
verticals and horizontals and and you
try to avoid that seasickness feeling
there's also an issue with exposure here
and this is something that you'll have
to make a choice about if you try to do
shots like this I'm going through all
sorts of different light sources and all
sorts of different levels of exposure
it's very dark then it's very bright
then it's very dark again and what we
did was we picked one exposure and we
stayed on state on that so you can see
that that sometimes I'm underexposed
sometimes I'm overexposed the windows
are blown out and the issue for you to
think about and there are actually
reasons to both is do you want to do it
that way do you want to leave the camera
on auto the problem with that being that
the camera will start breathing and
changing sometimes when you don't want
it to or do you want to manually change
your exposure as you go so you could
start out much much you know we had a
much higher f-stop and then you could
stop down as the as the bright light
hits the camera and then I'm going
you come around the corner here you
could you could open the iris again and
you have to do that manually while you
were walking which is a trick to learn
especially with these little cameras in
the little it's iris but but that it's a
choice to make which do you want to do
it's going to really depend on your
preference as a filmmaker and exactly
what kind of shot you're you're going
for
so here we have another following shot
there's a bit of a white balance issue
here so we're a bit orange I think we've
come in from outside so what I like
about that shot is the fact that you
start out in a very wide shot and coming
to a close up and that's really powerful
that's a very simple way of introducing
a character you know I see that's when I
go hey here the main character I'm
following this guy this is great so
that's really powerful there are you
know also some kind of neat frames and
the frame is changing in a nice way I
mean that you're showing off the
architecture of stata and at staircase
which is quite striking and then as I
said it's starting out in a very wide
shot and coming into a close-up white
balance again you change that you change
your shot you should always check your
white balance I mean unless it's really
the same lighting you want to change it
certainly if you come in to the interior
from being outside you need to real
white balance even within an environment
like stata or you've got overheads and
big windows and all sorts of mixed
lighting situations if you change you
want to check the white balance because
parts of stata are almost like daylight
and parts of stata are a very different
color temperature because they're all
very efflorescence they might have
halogens I mean there's all sorts of
crazy stuff going on in there so you
want to change and check every time so
here we have in filming an activity so
this is a close-up or what we call
sometimes an insert shot
nice shot
so the only thing there is you know you
had a really nice shot and you just hold
it don't worry about changing it it was
working really well and then suddenly
there was that decision to like oh wait
why'd it go why oh no wait i'm going to
not go wide and again it's it everyone
does that I mean even very experienced
camera people do that but making a
choice and sticking with it is is some
of the best advice I can give so if the
choice there was to go wide go all the
way wide show the whole scene and then
after you've done that for a few seconds
if that seems to have been may be the
wrong choice you can go back in but
going back and forth like sort of
censoring yourself going I want to be
white oh no I want to be close and and
in such as zooms I mean I've shown a
couple of examples of zooms but again
where I want to show Chris no I want to
show Dave no I want to show Sabrina no
you know that is how you end up with
with nothing so here we have another
zoom and again you know I'm not a huge
fan of zooms but that one kind of works
because it's revealing something again
there's an exposure issues it's it's
over exposed but you have this group of
people and you're revealing the
sculpture in the environment
now this is a very pretty shot which
again is sort of marred by that
indecisiveness so I could imagine that
same shot being the sort of very
beautiful environmental shot just with a
more decisive tilt up until down so you
could be doing a very sort of nice
smooth tilt up to the sky you can go all
the way to the sky or you could come
down from the sky you know reverse it
and find the people walking but whatever
you whatever you do you want to be
decisive so that you don't have that
sort of uncertainty in the camera and
see what I'm talking about that look
should I start okay I think I well where
am I going i'm not sure but again a very
pretty idea of a shot here we have a
really great shot nice self-portrait
the only thing I would say about that
again there's a little bit of sort of
indecisiveness at the end and it's the
kind of shot that would probably be
better on a tripod I mean you know you
may there may have been a time issue
like oh well you see this thing and you
don't want to set up the tripod and so
on and that sometimes that's
understandable but if you have time you
see a great shot like that if you set up
the tripod you'll have the same shot and
it'll just be nice and much smoother
because the the the energy or shakiness
of the handheld frame there doesn't
really add to the shot but it's great
you know it's a very pretty idea for
shot in it and it's a nice reveal of you
guys working so here we have I'm going
to end with a couple of voyeuristic
shots this one I mean there's an
exposure issue and a white balance issue
but I included it because you know it
feels a little bit you know voyeuristic
and the reason for that is that it's
shot on a long lens so everything's kind
of compressed it feels like the cameras
far away from from the action so imagine
shooting that same you know the same two
dogs that play you know on a wide lens
where you're right up in the action it
would feel really really different you
know you know whether you are handheld
or wide it would feel much more intimate
much more like the camera people were
connected to the action more like you
know you knew these dogs you knew the
owners you were sort of part of the of
the activity that is I mean it's a cool
shot it you know aside from the
technical issues but it and sometimes
you may want to do this intentionally
right it pushes us away from the action
it feels like we're we're kind of
viewing it from afar because literally
we are and speaking of voyeurism
so I included that again because first
of all it's a very interesting example
of a rack focus like revealing something
with focus and secondly because it feels
so voyeuristic obviously because of the
activity but also because of the way
it's framed it's a long lens we focus
into it see this little moment and then
we fade out so it's actually it's very
successful as a shot but it says a very
is a very specific way a very specific
emotional way of looking at that scene I
mean again imagine if you were right
down there with the people filming them
kissing that we've really different
because that would be kind of it would
there be an implicit consent that they
were you know that you were there they
were there you that that there was there
was much more intimacy this is this is
for better or worse very very very
distant and it's and it's cool I mean it
works I'm not I'm not saying it doesn't
work I'm saying it gives you a very
specific emotional read of the situation
and the cameras relationship you know it
does is that kiss more illicit than the
kiss that you would have filmed closer
it feels a lot more illicit and then the
last shot here the key no I think this
is a very cool shot this was our open
course for a camera person
so I thought that was a very pretty shot
in a nice way to end it so anyway any
thoughts or questions about any of this
stuff it is concerns
okay so what I thought we would do next
and it's going to take a minute or two
to set up is just talk a little bit
about some of the the things that that
came up in in this stuff we're going to
try to set up hook up a camera to the
projector I can show you a couple of
things that you can be thinking about
when you shoot and then we're going to
talk a bit more about film grammar
before we switch over to audio so let's
see I guess I should unplug this
yeah i mean this won't take too long but
here we go
okay so let's just start talking about
you know setting up a shot here I mean
this is not a very appealing shot it's
the white balance is wrong the good
chance to talk about angles if you shoot
from below rather than above well yeah
but let's first talk about white balance
and exposure because this is not this is
not happening so how would I how would I
fix this first thing I want to do of
course is make sure that my white
balance is correct if I don't have a
piece of paper I can grab something else
so that is probably close enough for now
second thing I might want to do is get a
rough exposure so I'm going to I'm
exposing up now what exactly my exposure
is here might depend on my frame and
i'll show you what i mean if i zoom in
on Dave I get my focus
and I'm you know I may want to expose
more if I'm really going to be in
close-up on Dave i also have a head face
to get those shadows under the eyes
because my oh stop making excuse all
right so this would be like a close-up
potentially you know it's a really tough
lighting situation i might ask gabe to
move if I felt like I could depending on
the environment yeah I'm afraid to them
so if i go out wide again see now it
looks really overexposed so again i'm
going to adjust my exposure a little bit
you know I what's really killing me is
the backlight of the window so what I
could say is excuse me sir could you
take a step just a little forward please
thank you
and now
I'm sorry
so now it's a little bit easier to go
get a proper exposure
so the the trick with it with focus
which I don't think we emphasized enough
last week is that if you're in a tough
focus situation or pretty much in any
situation what you want to do is zoom in
and get focus and in in the case of
shooting people what you what you want
to be in focus are the eyes and then you
can zoom back out to whatever frame it
is that you wanted to to have so you
know even if I'm way out here and here i
might want to you know go down in terms
of much exposure a little bit you know
his eyes are what I cared about being in
focus and you know again if I come over
here I might want to reach Ainge my
white balance because this is a very
mixed situation Dave is much more in
daylight over here then he would be over
here so you know I might want to change
my my white balance again and remember
again the white balance is set to the
assign button on the right of the camera
so I'm going to zoom in on a piece of
paper
well I mean yeah bring-bring white paper
with you looks a little that looks
really does Leslie doesn't it doesn't
seem like a very good white balance
Joanna a hold of yeah right the table
was not a really good choice actually
but um but this seems
anyway
then everything will be off by that
about that percent so yeah what what
Dennis mentioned was that this i SAT it
to a table here which isn't really white
you know it's got a little bit of sort
of yellowish in it so so that was you
know I'm fooling the camera a little bit
and you can do that intentionally but
it's probably better to do that kind of
thing in post-production so yeah if you
get an approximation it's pretty easy to
fix white balance and post right so and
yet some of the things that we just
looked at that we're off you couldn't
you know probably are somewhat fixable
so that looks better yeah so again this
is a different white balance than the
other side of the room now one thing the
day was talking about you know we talked
about camera angles a lot on Wednesday
night we talked about ver tile we talked
about Nanak of the north and the way the
camera gets used in both of those and
you know to go back to Dave here for a
minute you know think about the
difference between you know this shot
and this shot
you know and this shot you know a giant
Dave strip in its giant of film and then
this is the you know the sort of the
flirty you know I know this guy I'm
going to I'm going to learn more about
this guy kind of feeling and this is the
you know the sort of spy cam voyeuristic
make Dave look small kind of being
vulnerable so how you choose to and
that's just one example but how you how
you choose your shots throughout and and
whether you're choosing to be on a
tripod or handheld how you're moving the
camera has an emotional resonance it's
very important so do you want to just go
over like those sort of basic controls
again of the camera just one last time I
don't know if you want to have this
plugged in or out that can't leave it
plugged in okay and then we'll talk a
little bit about sort of putting shots
together let me it's again just basics
the zoom is in the blood the back right
of the camera so go tight go wide it's
also right here on the LCD screen know
if you want to zoom in Dennis you know
last time I didn't hold positions long
enough so on the actual LCD screen you
can see a double unity for wide and
telephoto it's a much slower controlled
zoom this is pressure sensitive in the
back so it depends on the situation
which one you want to use the focus ring
I would just keep this switch right here
all the way on the back on manual focus
because this is the only ring you have a
lot of cameras have three rings they
have one for aperture 14 focus one for
zoom but since this is the only the soul
the only ring you have I would keep this
for focus and just use a zoom on the
back right or on the LCD panel
again exposure is right here the lever
sorry if for some reason or another
you're not getting the focus bar in the
LCD screen this is a little button right
behind the lever and just press that so
I pressed it down I have no control over
exposure but if you press it again you
get the access to the focus lever or the
exposure lever I think this button right
here switches between volume control you
can use this for volume controller you
can use it for exposure so if it's never
working correctly you're not changing
the exposure at all just press the
little button that's behind it and that
should that should fix your problem
let's see should i do menu so just maybe
just you know when I picked up that
camera today it was set in all auto okay
so it might be just a good to talk about
how you get out of auto because one of
the things that you may find is that
it's an autofocus it's an auto white
balance it's an auto exposure oh yeah
the one we used on the stream that's
right yeah so so if you happen to get a
camera like that that's been set that
way it's it's good to know pretty
quickly how to get out of that so let's
just do that and then I can move on
right here the one that you set for
manual focus if you there are three
options you can put it all the way to
the back which is manual focus you can
put it in the middle which is auto focus
so let's just assume can I easy for
example how'd he do let's just zoom in
here
if I oh that's right we just mess focus
let's put it on auto focus and there you
go so if you're ever in a situation like
say you're doing handheld stuff and
you're working hard to follow somebody
you may want to use auto focus if you're
staying wide and you're following that
person at a relatively close in a
relatively close banner so in some
instances it's good to have but for the
most part I would recommend manual focus
your hands oh yeah sure sure so I'm
gonna put it on manual focus and just
mess up the focus and once you switch it
to auto focus it snaps right into focus
at the front of this three switch these
three through this three switch is zoom
and you can set this ring right here to
zoom if you push this all the way to the
front and now this ring acts as a zoom
ring so but again
I would keep this on focus manual focus
at the very back on the right-hand side
of the camera again the assign button is
right here and this is for white
balancing so again find a white sheet of
paper if you're with somebody else just
have them whole but hold it up to
whatever your dominant light sources
zoom in try to fill the frame about 80%
with the white paper press this a sign
button and it should white balance for
you you should see a little blinking
what looks like a flower in the LCD
panel when it's done blinking that means
you're properly white balance and of
course you'll see the color change in
the actual LCD screen so let's see other
auto features you have to go into the
menu a little bit actually I think you
have to go to the main menu for exposure
and you can't get really mirrored here
in the main menu not the personal menu
if you want to go to auto exposure which
is a good idea if you leave the camera
alone and you're going to have a lot of
like changes and lighting if you go to
camera set I don't know if you can this
might be a little weird a camera set in
the main menu not the personal menu but
the bigger menu and you go to exposure
you have a choice of auto or manual and
if you're just going to set the camera
up on a tripod and again there's going
to be changes in the lighting in the
room I would go it would auto
what else okay yeah and the second half
of class everyone's going to get the
sound package and the camera package and
practice working with them together that
is also might that might be a good time
for you to just look at some of these at
settings again and talk to you there
Dave RI if you have questions or aren't
sure about you know how to get from one
kind of setting to another or how does
how to do a focus and exposure a white
balance it's going to take a little bit
of practice until it becomes kind of
second nature so before we move over to
sound and we'll take a quick break
before we do that I want to talk a
little just a bit more about putting
shots together what we've been kind of
calling film grammar so thinking back to
the films that we looked at on Wednesday
night what kinds of shots were they
using give me some ideas of the kinds of
things we saw
like ride a decision
right so wide shots will call them what
else mm-hmm close-ups of people right
what else
medium shots right which is kind of the
in-between right so
what about bear talk how was he using
the camera differently
right extreme angles which are any of
these could also be an extreme angle but
that's definitely worth putting up here
in in Nanak there's the scene with the
fishing what other kinds of shots did
you see in that scene if you remember
right now there was a it was also
zooming in and I don't think actually
zooms exactly yes so focusing on the
fish is is it is a different kind of
shot and that has different names but
what I'll call it free for now is what's
often referred to as the insert shot and
what that means is it's what you know
you insert it in the middle of the
action to show a close-up of an activity
so for existence the shot of paying for
the food in the in the line is kind of
an insert shot and it's definitely worth
putting up here you want to tie that in
to cover that's where I'm going oh yeah
so anything else think about like ver
tov think about the shots of the people
in the carriage the trains right moving
shots
and that could be handheld like we were
doing or it could be a fixed shot it
could be what we call a dolly shot if
except we don't have a dolly but if you
could be mounted in a car as very tough
was you could be mounted on a train or a
streetcar the generic term for that
which might be like a dolly shot with
the idea being that that would be
smoother than a handheld shot because
you're on some kind of wheeled vehicle
on a tripod probably so oh this is not
at all a mutually exclusive list I mean
a moving shot could be a wide shot it
could be a close-up it could be a medium
shot could even be an insert shot
extreme angles could be any of these
handheld you could have a handheld wide
shot a handheld close-up so so this is
not an exclusive list but if you look at
these wide shot close-up medium shot
insert shot that's going to cover a lot
of the kind of thing that you're going
to be shooting and they fit together in
very specific in particular ways and
that's what we really refer to as film
grammar and these other things as I said
all of these things could be one of
these or anything else
so I'll pick up the camera in a minute
but let's say we're filming a scene of
two people talking and I'm going to I'm
drawing it from overhead these are their
noses right okay so how might we shoot
that scene
right so what you're referring to is
what we call it word is typically
referred to as the line and this is kind
of a basic concept in in filmmaking
which is your sounds like you're
familiar with but the rest of you may
not be the idea of the line is that
whatever scene you're shooting whether
it's a simple scene of two people or
even one person or a more complicated
seen you draw an imaginary line through
the center of it like that and that axis
gives you kind of a frame of reference
to shoot the scene and as long as you
stay on one side of the other of the
line the shots that you shoot make sense
when they are put together that's kind
of in editing so what I mean by that is
let's say where we come down here if you
can see that and film a wide shot from
the side of the two people talking so if
we do that person one is looking camera
right the right side of their looking to
the right side of the lens and person to
is looking to the left now if I put the
camera anywhere else along that axis or
along the side of the axis they're still
going to be looking the same direction
so I could come over here and film over
their shoulder and they're still looking
camera right less so but still and
they're still looking camera left I
could come over here and do the same
thing can shoot close-ups I can shoot
wide shots I could you know if they were
working at something together I could
shoot insert shots of whatever it is
that they're doing and the hands would
still be all oriented the same way
person 1 is always oriented to the right
and person to is oriented to the left
but if I come over here is if I cross
the line and start shooting on this side
all of a sudden it's completely flipped
person one is now looking to the left
and in editing the sort of the standard
the standard form of editing is that
that gets is considered jarring or
confusing it's not
it doesn't flow as smoothly if you start
cutting those shots together now in 2011
those rules are really not hard and fast
rules i mean you know Quentin Tarantino
started crossing the line while he
wasn't the first but but at this point
in in terms of filmmaking we accept all
sorts of things and we don't worry as
much about it but when you're starting
out figuring out how to shoot scenes I
think it's important to know these rules
and then later learn how to break them
so let's just quickly is it we set the
camera let me show you what I mean it's
probably easier
let's see so Dennis I'm blocking you
right yeah mm-hmm ok come over here okay
so so David I he took a night have you
guys do our little scene let's say
you're talking and I'm going to come
around here simply because if you could
just weren't yourself so the windows not
behind you just great a little Dave
l'amour this one yeah okay see any good
movies okay
at once
okay so UC Davis looking camera left and
she's looking camera right dave is
looking camera left she's looking camera
right she's still looking camera right
another year another year I had Davis
looking camera right I mean camera left
Davis looking camera left and if they
were you know if they were actually
working together on some kind of
activity they would still be looking the
same way oh so my line it goes through
the center of the scene just as we
described if I come over here all of a
sudden suddenly she's looking camera
left because I cross the line I said oh
I missed that so that's the basic
concept of the line and it can get
confusing if you have a very complicated
scene like again imagine this classroom
imagine somebody up here talking and the
rest of you listening if I stay on this
side of the classroom this person is
always looking to the right and everyone
here is looking to the left dennis is
shooting to the left but if I go over
there all of a sudden it's reversed so
that's kind of the basic concept of film
grammar and as I said it's broken all
the time sometimes intentionally
sometimes unintentionally and people
have gotten a lot more used to reading
scenes when it's broken but it's kind of
a still a basic thing that you want to
get familiar with and you want to use to
to film your basic scenes before you
sort of understand how to how to not do
it or when it's when it's good to not do
it one example of when you might want to
change would be to change the sort of
the feel of a space if you're shooting
the same space for a long time so for
instance if if I was doing a documentary
on this class and I was in here for
three hours
at some point I might change on purpose
so that I I create a kind of a new
feeling in the class so maybe I would
film the camera part looking this way
with it with with the film grammar set
up on this axis and then maybe when we
switch to sound I go over there and film
this way although these windows we might
dictate my choice this is would be a
very difficult background but but in
other words you know you can change and
you can switch but that's also a
situation in which i probably wouldn't
be intercutting the first stuff that I
shot with the second stuff that I shot
so it's just it's a way of helping your
audience just kind of feel comfortable
in the scene understand where people are
accept everything and although there are
plenty of times that you may want to
intentionally break it so that makes
sense questions
yeah okay the only other thing that I'll
talk about just quickly is a focal
length I mean I I talked a bit about
that sort of voyeuristic field that you
get with a long lens that is one issue
to think about and again remember that
the the the focal length that you shoot
on is not the same as the size of the
shot so I'm right now shooting as wide
as I possibly can and now I'm shooting a
close-up because I went to a very long
lens it's the study shot I would
probably not no it's not that's ok so I
however I can also shoot a close-up on a
very wide lens which will have a
different feel for one thing it's
smoother if you're shooting handheld but
it also tends to change people's faces
long lenses are actually very flattering
to the human face so if you want to make
people look good shooting on a longer
lens is a good idea it also changes the
relationship between foreground and
background you see all of a sudden the
background is completely in focus which
means that we are less likely to pick
out the face if I come back here and go
back to a long lens
the background starts to get soft and
you can see how shaky it is too I'm the
steady shot isn't on either now I don't
have enough room in here but the other
thing that you can do of course is have
a wide shot that's on a long lens if I
got back another 50 yards I could have a
nice wide shot of this room on the
farthest most telephoto focal length and
that is when you start to get into kind
of voyeuristic territory may think again
about that shot through the bars of the
the kissing that was shot it's a widest
shot shot on a long lens but again your
your depth of field is very shallow so
you can do things like rack focus in and
out it can be very a very beautiful kind
of way to shoot things but it has a
particular emotional kind of feeling so
thoughts questions about this stuff
before we take a break and switch into
sound
there are your feelings as long
but zoomed in on this camera you know
zoomed all the way in the longest focal
length meaning the field of view of the
lenses as narrow as it can possibly be
okay all right well so let's take a
five-minute break and then when we come
back we'll do a quick introduction to
audio recording and an introduction to
our audio package and then we'll get a
chance to spend some time playing around
with both the camera and the audio gear